- Welcome to The Kelly Clarkson Show
in part taping right in my home.
Yep, I'm still in
COVID/flu/cold recovery protocol
so I have a little bit more time
to be home for the holidays.
♪ Home for the holidays ♪
All right, but we've got a
whole audience in the studio
truly in the Christmas spirit.
Let me hear y'all, give it to me!
(audience cheering)
And as always, we're gonna
dive straight in with music
except this is a little different,
and I'm very excited.
Instead of a standard Kelly-oke,
I have a good friend and
super talented singer.
She's right there to lift you up
with a signature song of the season.
You're gonna love this.
It's beautiful.
It's a Jewel-aoke
of "Have Yourself a
Merry Little Christmas."
(audience cheering)
♪ Have yourself a merry little Christmas ♪
♪ Let your heart be light ♪
♪ From now on our troubles
will be out of sight ♪
♪ Through the years we
all will be together ♪
♪ If the fates allow ♪
♪ To hang our shining ♪
♪ Hang a shining star
above the highest bough ♪
♪ And have yourself ♪
♪ A merry little Christmas ♪
♪ Now ♪
(audience cheering)